hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es wieder
eine geburtstagstorte von mir eigentlich
ist geburtstagstorte ja quatsch denn ihr
könnt diese portos sie jedem anlass
machen aber ich finde die sieht so
festlich aus das passt einfach auf dem
geburtstagstisch deshalb nenne ich jetzt
einfach mal schoko vanille
geburtstagstorte aber die ist halt eher
chocolatier will gleich sehen warum ich
habe die böden diesmal schon vorbereitet
ich habe extra basic rezept auf einem
kanal damit so videos wie dieses hier
zum beispiel nicht so unendlich lang
gehen und ihr euch gelangweilt fühlt es
gibt eben diese basic rezepte und anhand
dieser rezepte habe ich meine zwei
bühnen vorbereitet hans idee war es ein
vanille und schoko bizkit zu backen habe
ich auch gemacht bin gespannt wie das
dahinter im anschnitt aussieht und genau
ich schreibe euch alle genauen
mengenangaben wie ich jetzt für diese
zwecke verwendet hier unten in die
infobox genauso wie sämtliche anderen
mengenangaben und noch ein kleiner
hinweis ich möchte lieber eine kleine
und dafür hohe torte haben deshalb habe
ich hier 18 cm böden gebacken und wir
fangen jetzt aber direkt an mit den
nächsten zutaten zuerst einmal benötigen
wir zeit bitterschokolade hier könnt ihr
auch gerne kuba türe nehmen außerdem
schlag sahne und butter so ihr lieben
wir benutzen diese cremes für erst am
ende des videos denn wir machen jetzt
eine art forsting das nutzen wir dann
später auch für außen herum aber es
macht mehr sinn jetzt schon zuzubereiten
der nickel zeit dauert ein bisschen bis
bz am herd und in meinen kochtopf gebe
ich jetzt einfach sahne und butter und
dass es einmal aufkochen
[Musik]
dass butter sahne gemischt das kocht
jetzt und an der stelle mache ich den
herd aus jetzt gehen wir die tat bitter
schokolade in eine ausreichend große
schüssel wie hier ist etwas zu klein so
und das sind einfach darüber gießen dann
schmilzt das ganze schon so ein bisschen
und ich gebe jetzt auch noch einen
teller drüber damit das ganze so ein
bisschen besser schmelzen kann und den
fünf minuten ruhig das ganze dann schön
um
[Musik]
also noch ist es total flüssig und man
kann sich gar nicht vorstellen dass
daraus später ein schönes fest das
frosting geht aber es ist wirklich so
will dass man sie jetzt vollständig
auskühlen gibt es auch noch in den
kühlschrank und biss sich dann mit der
restlichen torte fertig bin ist das auch
abgekühlt und dann haben ein fertiges
frosting und weiter geht's mit unserer
füllung ich habe mir überlegt wir machen
eine schoko sahne flo und ich mache das
ganze so ein bisschen cremiger mit hilfe
von doppel ram frischkäse viele sagen
man schmeckt es raus finde ich
persönlich gar nicht wenn das macht mir
so unangenehmen und geschmack und falls
ihr fragt wodurch ihr das setzen könnt
das schreibe ich euch ebenfalls in
infobox jetzt will ich gar nicht weiter
auf die folter spannen und zeigt euch
die zutaten wir benötigen kalte
schlagsahne doppel rahm frischkäse
puderzucker außerdem vanille zucker
kakao und sahne fest und für die schoko
sahne dem ich jetzt die küchenmaschine
natürlich könnt ihr euer handrührgerät
verwenden um zählt genauso gut und jetzt
gebe ich zuallererst doppel ram
frischkäse in die schüssel und dazu gebe
ich noch toller zucker und vanillezucker
und die drei zutaten rührt er jetzt auf
niedriger geschwindigkeit so ungefähr
ein paar sekunden 20 sekunden reichen ja
schon und dann las sie später noch den
kakao einrieseln
den cacau nach und nach dazu geben denn
in der back also kein trinker
konkurrenten und der ist stark enthüllt
das heißt er ist sehr trocken und falls
ihr merkt das ist alles so ein bisschen
zu fest und lässt sich nicht mehr so gut
rhön sowie jetzt zum beispiel gibt ihr
nach und nach die sahne mit dazu die
zahlung bis eisig kalt sein
und ich mache die maschine jetzt noch
mal kurz aus und manche ganz groß was zu
erklären gibt ja die sahne mit dazu und
ihr schlagt sie danach auf vollster
stufe richtig schön auf aber nicht zu
lange sonst erhaltet ihr mutter und das
wäre total schade ich gebe es noch den
rest dazu es hat sich alles gut
miteinander verbunden
wie gesagt höchste stufe und dann das
tier auch nach und landes seine fest
einrieseln
[Musik]
so nicht länger als eine minute hat das
hier bei mir gedauert mit einem
handrührgerät kann es vielleicht ein
bisschen länger dauern vielleicht zwei
minuten
aber wie gesagt nicht zuviel schlagen
sonst wäre es nämlich wirklich schade
und die creme ist jetzt fertig und wir
machen weiter so die creme ist fertig
und jetzt müssen wir uns nur noch den
böden widmen ich schneide ich jetzt
durch und ich hab mir grad zu überlegt
man hat ja sonst immer ganz normal dicke
böden zu zweieinhalb zentimeter ich
möchte diesmal mehrere bürden haben und
dünne und durch die farbe auf die haben
sie mich ja gebracht hat durch diesen
farbunterschiede sie das dann richtig
cool aus dem antritt wenn die böden halt
dünnen sind und sich ganz oft abwechseln
meine böden sind jetzt 4 cm hoch
beziehungsweise viereinhalb ich
orientiere mich aber an den vier
zentimetern und schneit jeden boden so
ungefähr 1,3 zentimeter hose vermissen
wird es sehr viele zahlen aber er
versteht sicher was ich meine das ganze
nach back das heißt ich teile beide
böden durch 3
[Musik]
so die böden sind bereit die habe ich
ihm schöne dünne scheibchen geschnitten
das weibchen ist jetzt echt übertrieben
aber sie sind schon dünner als normal
und ich finde es richtig gut also mir
gefällt die optik jetzt schon jetzt
müssen wir die kuchen aber noch gefüllt
also die böden und dafür habe ich jetzt
hier einfach eine tolle platte nimmt
einfach die die am liebsten mag ich
nehme es eine hohe damit die noch höher
wird die torte und ich nehme zu hilfe
mein tortenring und geschichte ich jetzt
schritt für schritt creme mit boden und
ich bin ein bisschen verrückt heute weil
ich will das einfach akkurat und
gleichmäßig haben deshalb habe ich die
creme abgebogen und nehmen jede schicht
fünf zwischenschichten sind insgesamt
über 220 gramm das ist ein fünftel
meiner kleinen jeweils und schichten
jetzt ganz einfach
[Musik]
so ich bin schon ziemlich weit nördlich
angekommen also es ist jetzt die letzte
schicht creme die verteidigt jetzt noch
und ich wollte euch ja mal ganz gut was
zeigen und zwar seht ihr hier den
tortenring mag ihn ja total
aber der trend geht ja jetzt immer mehr
zu hohen torten bzw
ich möchte dass der trend zu hohen
torten geht und lieber vom durchmesser
her kleinere torten und es gibt bald was
ganz neues ich werde euch dann aber noch
informieren also keine sorge und jetzt
habe ich den tortenring etwas höher
geschoben damit ich hier eben auch meine
creme verteilen kann aber bald müssen
wir das nicht aber seid gespannt ich
will noch nicht zu viel verraten so die
letzte schicht creme ist drauf und jetzt
gebe ich noch den deckel drüber
hier habe ich einfach den hellen boden
wie gesagt immer abwechseln und hier
habe ich wirklich den boden weil das ein
schöner gerade abschluss ist gibt ihm
jetzt noch da drauf und ich wickle meine
bizkit bullen würden immer ganz gerne in
frischhaltefolie einen denn bis werden
das ist einfach so wenn die reine luft
stehen dann werden sie trocken
es ist leider so aber man kann ja
entgegenwirken und die habe ich die
folie von grado ich schmeiß sie mir weg
sondern verwendet ihr dann halt wieder
weil die sind ja noch total sauber und
jetzt einfach richtig schön abdecken
auch hier unten die seiten und dann
können wir das ganze für 30 minuten und
dann machen wir weiter
[Musik]
so sieht die torte jetzt aus gefällt mir
jetzt schon nackig richtig gut aber wir
wollen wir jetzt noch einkleiden und
jetzt wollte ich euch gerne mal unser
frosting zeigen ich habe jetzt so ein
bisschen mit ein bisschen kraftaufwand
gerührt aber er sehe das frosting ist
richtig schön fest geworden und trotzdem
noch so geschmeidig dass man eine torte
damit jetzt erhöhen kann
und genau das mache ich jetzt und ich
mache die schicht auch nicht zu dick
sondern einfach so dass es schick
aussieht
[Musik]
die schokoladen torte ist jetzt richtig
schön glatt eingestrichen und wie gesagt
die creme ist wirklich sehr schön fest
ihr könnt sie wenn sie in der küche zu
warm ist noch für zehn minuten in den
kühlschrank tun müsst ihr aber nicht
also meinem fall war das jetzt nicht
nötig obwohl sie immer sehr erfahren ist
durch die ganzen licht und jetzt kuriere
ich das ganze schön nach motto
schokolade schokolade schokolade ich
habe jetzt hier einmal so schoko ich
weiß gar nicht wie man das nämlich zeigt
sich mal von ganz nah an die sehen
nämlich richtig hübsch aus und die werde
ich jetzt hier unten an der torte
platzieren und die haften dann richtig
gut durch die creme
[Musik]
alles klar die streusel halten richtig
gut wie einst und jetzt machen wir den
grip für mich gibt es keine pompöse
torte ohne grip ich finde es immer so
schön wir machen hatte die schoko die
habe ich ganz einfach schokolade
geschmolzen in der mikrowelle hotel zu
beginn genauen mengenangaben schreibe
ich euch natürlich wie immer in die
infobox schneidet vorne einfach die
spitze ab und dann machen wir den grip
[Musik]
so die torte hatte ich jetzt noch mal
für zehn minuten im kühlschrank der mit
der trip auch richtig schön festwirt und
jetzt machen wir weiter jetzt nehme ich
mit meinen torten einteiler habe hier
zwölf teile und jetzt drücke ich einmal
ganz leicht drauf damit ich mir nicht
stellen markiert und als nächstes nehme
ich mir mein spritzbeutel ich habe ich
die übrig also das übrige frosting
eingegeben ihr werdet genug übrig haben
macht euch da gar keine sorgen
dann müsst ihr nicht extra was neues
anrühren und hier habe ich so eine
offene stelle dran und da spritze ich
jetzt ganz einfach sie zu häufchen
[Musik]
so ich habe mir jetzt eigentlich
überlegt das soll so von anfang an der
plan dass ich noch waffel blätter
obendrauf reinstecken und ich habe das
team mal ausprobiert das mache ich sie
mal ganz gerne dass ich ein extra
tellern im mietvertrag spitze und schaue
wie das aussieht das gefällt mir aber
gar nicht mehr so gut deswegen lasse ich
das denn ich für die torte mich perfekt
und falls ihr euch wundert die heute
soll für zwölf leute reichen sie ist
zwar sehr klein aber weil sie falsch
schokolade ist auch ein bisschen mächtig
aber nicht so dass man sagt born auch
ein bisschen bin ich top sagt ich habe
ja meine schneidtechnik für mich so ein
bisschen gefunden und zwar habe ich das
in zwölf stücke geteilt und gleichzeitig
aber immer ein stück noch mal in der
mitte das heißt diese torte die
eigentlich nur 18 cm im durchmesser ist
ein ziemlich hoher es reicht für 24
personen ich zeigt sich aber gleich
nochmal
[Musik]
ihr habt den anschluss gesehen mir
gefällt der richtig gut an der stelle
danke haben dafür die idee ich habe
nicht gedacht dass ich so wirklich als
ich dachte das ist so gut aussehen
danke haben also auch vor allem jetzt
mit dem anschnitt mit dem dass man das
tier das in der hälfte durchschneidet
das ist alles so tipps die könnt ihr
gerne mitnehmen
ihr könnt eure liebsten am
überraschenden oder vielleicht zum
geburtstag doch nicht zum geburtstag es
gibt genug ereignisse damit nicht mehr
ganz sicher
die genauen mengenangaben schreibe ich
euch wie immer unten in den druck
gewünscht die ganze team ist
wir müssen jetzt sehen wie motive
geburtstagstorte für männer
wir hatten genau werden falls die pinka
version aber es gibt auch mehr die pink
mögen das sage ich auch immer ganz gern
dazu also ich freue mich wenn das ganze
nach macht haben für die leute ich muss
euch dass irgendwann mal zeigen wie der
sich ein upgrade zu derrick kamera beim
nächsten mal so jetzt würde ich ganz
viel spaß zum nachbacken der leckere
torte und ich freue mich auf jeden fall
über fotos mit dem hashtag des kitchen
auf instagram schickt mir alle eure
fotos ich will hier sehen ich will
unbedingt wissen wie ihr das gemacht
habt und dann freue ich mich wenn ihr
beim nächsten mal auch wieder
einschaltet auf klischees kitchen